[SLIDE CLICKS]
INTERVIEWER: These
uniquely-colored pools sitting
in what looks like the
literal middle of nowhere
are no doubt strange, but
they're also somewhat familiar.
If you've ever stared out
the window of an airplane,
you must have seen something
like this, different patterns,
grids, and shapes.
It's a perspective
that you can only
get when traveling thousands
of feet in the air.
ALEXANDER HEILNER: Hi, my
name is Alexander Heilner.
I am a photographer
and an artist
living in Baltimore, Maryland.
I teach at the Maryland
Institute College
of Art or MICA, where I'm
a professor of photography
and digital imaging.
INTERVIEWER: Alexander is a
specific type of photographer
who enjoys taking pictures from
a different angle than most.
ALEXANDER HEILNER:
For many, many years,
I've been making a lot of
artwork and particularly
landscape photography,
which is really
focused on where the natural
and artificial elements
of our world coexist.
About 10 years ago, I began
hiring small planes and pilots
to take a look at the
landscape from up above
and start documenting
places where
it seemed like we'd been leaving
huge marks on the landscape.
INTERVIEWER: And one of the
landscapes that caught his eye
was this place, a potash
mine in southern Utah.
ALEXANDER HEILNER: Potash
is a substance that
has been used since ancient
times for a number of uses,
but in the last couple
hundred years has mainly
been used as a fertilizer.
And just basically, it's
one of the main ways
of getting potassium,
which is one
of the most fundamental elements
that plants need to grow well.
INTERVIEWER: The potash
is hidden away underground
so mining companies pump
water down after it,
flushing it out into
these great big pools
where they sit until all
the water has evaporated,
leaving only the potash.
ALEXANDER HEILNER:
In June of 2007,
I was flying across the
country on a commercial flight
from New York to San Francisco
and I looked out my window
somewhere on the
middle of the flight.
And way off in the
distance, in the middle
of a stark, red
desert landscape were
these amazing
pools of blue water
just shimmering on the horizon.
It was absolutely magical.
It's rare that I've seen
anything that stunning
and that surprising even
in all the flying I've
done back and forth
across the country.
INTERVIEWER: Alexander was
so transfixed by the sight
that he soon returned,
hired a small airplane,
and shot these photos.
ALEXANDER HEILNER:
The abstract ones
are really beautiful
and really amazing
in a way that really engages
your eye and your senses
and asks you questions almost
about what is photography
and what is painting
and what is mining
and what is the landscape.
I think almost any
place can be the subject
of an amazing photograph.
I hope that these images
are inspiring to others
to look around and see their
world a little bit differently.
INTERVIEWER: If you want to
see more unique perspectives
from around the world,
watch this episode
on the mysterious Marfa
ghost lights in Texas
or check out this one on the
wild wonders of Yellowstone
National Park.
And don't forget to subscribe.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]